the controversial law in Texas banning
so-called sanctuary cities faces
resistant from law enforcement officials
across the state governor Greg Abbott
signed the measure known as SB 4 on
Sunday police and local officials could
face $25,000 fines or jail time if they
don't help enforce u.s. immigration law
David beg no spoke with the travis
county sheriff who was singled out by
the governor when he signed the law
David good morning Charlie good morning
the law goes into effect September 1st
let me tell you how it all got started
you have this new sheriff in Travis
County who came into office and said I
don't have the resources to enforce
federal immigration law all the time so
I'm not and the governor of Texas said
really you better or I'm going to take
away some state funding and we're going
to pass a law that could jail you or
remove you from office well the sheriff
didn't flinch and the governor made good
on his word I think it's bad for our
community in Austin Texas
Travis County Sheriff Sally Hernandez
says SB 4 hurts her deputies ability to
fight crime we have witnesses that are
undocumented that see a crime but
they're not going to feel comfortable
coming forward but governor Greg Abbott
says police cannot pick and choose which
laws they want to enforce he believes s
before we'll keep criminals off the
street this law cracks down policies
like the Travis County Sheriff who
declare that she would not detain known
criminals accused of violent crimes
misinformation based on fear I honor
detainers for the more violent crimes
like rape and murder right many Texas
sheriffs and police chiefs oppose the
new law saying they don't have the
resources to enforce federal immigration
law they also fear that SB 4 which
allows officers to ask crime victims or
witnesses their immigration status could
lead to racial profiling I think you
will see lawsuits from the different
organizations where individuals may feel
they're being targeted SP 4 has been
compared to Arizona's so-called show
your papers law which sparked protests
and boycotts in 2010 before it was
largely struck down by a federal court
and sheriff Hernandez hopes SB 4 dies
the same way if the law goes
to affect what are you going to do I
will have to change my policy because I
will not violate the law so the ACLU has
put out a travel advisory telling people
not to come to Texas because of the new
law
Norah yesterday the state of Texas filed
something of a preemptive strike the
Attorney General went to court and sued
the city of Austin he's trying to get a
judge to declare this new law
constitutional essentially trying to
shut down any further lawsuits against
the law quite a story David thank you so
much